Speaker 1: Let's continue cataloging and
evaluating some of the different reactions
from right wing figures to the invasion of Ukraine
by Russian President Vladimir Putin over the last
few hours. And things are changing so rapidly that
it is hard to say this is where things are right
now. But at least over the last few hours, we
have not learned of any further push into Ukraine
so far. Vladimir Putin has recognized separatists
in the Donetsk and Luhansk regions as independent
and then sent troops in to keep the peace on the
basis that these are now independent separatists
who want to be part of Russia. Donald Trump
on a podcast interview we played last segment,
thought that it was genius, savvy and smart.
Donald Trump also put out a written statement
about what is going on in Russia, Ukraine
and as usual, it is riddled with the same
contradictions and confusions that we have
seen from Donald Trump for a long time. I
will read it to you. Donald Trump publishing
this yesterday quote If properly handled,
there was absolutely no reason that the current
that the situation currently happening in Ukraine
should have happened at all. I know Vladimir Putin
very well, and he would have never done during the
Trump administration what he is doing now. No way.
Now missing in that that there's already a lot to
analyze there. And I know that it's easy to just
see the things Trump says and kind of write them
off as the rantings of a lunatic and that that you
would not be wrong to do that. But when he says
Putin never would have done this during the Trump
administration. What Trump wants you to believe
is that Putin was scared of Trump,
and so he never would have tried this
during the Trump administration. The problem
with that is twofold. Number one, Trump and the
right's whole attitude to Putin during the Trump
administration was We should be nice to Putin,
not that we should be tough with Putin. So Trump's
idea that Putin wouldn't have done this during the
Trump administration because Trump's so tough goes
directly counter to the narrative they were giving
us, which is Trump is friendly and correct to be
friendly with Vladimir Putin. That's number one.
The second piece is it's possible.
Let's imagine that Trump is right.
Putin would never even have thought of this during
the Trump administration. One possible reason why
Putin would not have thought of would not think
of doing this during the Trump administration
would be that he feels as though he doesn't need
to, because the world attitude to Putin is much
more friendly thanks to Trump and one foreign
policy analysis. One section of foreign foreign
policy analysis about why Putin is doing this
now is well. With Trump gone and Biden here.
The global community is more hostile to Russia
when it comes to Naito expansion, when it comes to
whatever. Nord Stream, etc. And so Putin feels
he needs to do something. So I'm not saying
any one of these analyzes is the right one.
But there are many reasons why Trump could be,
in a literal sense, correct that misstate
the reasons behind it. OK, let's continue
back to the quote Russia has become very,
very rich during the Biden administration,
with oil prices doubling and soon to be tripling
and quadrupling. Now Trump is trying to link
Biden to gas prices going up and of course,
gas prices. Oil prices rather started going
up during the Trump administration due to the
resurgence in demand as COVID started to wane,
or at least we thought it was starting to wane.
And so that increase started under Trump, and it
simply continued under Joe Biden. Presidents have
very little that they can do about gas prices and
oil prices. There's Strategic Petroleum Reserve.
We've talked about that, but it is. It is not
even fair to say that it is related to Biden,
but Donald Trump wants you to think that it
is. Lastly, the weak sanctions are insignificant
relative to taking over a country and a massive
piece of strategically located land. So here Trump
is acting tough. Now it has begun, oil prices are
going higher and higher, Putin is not only getting
what he always wanted, but getting because of the
oil and gas surge richer and richer. The
US was energy independent under the Trump
administration. We actually still are. We did that
story Monday and independence we never had before.
Oil prices would have remained low. Now what a
mess our country is in. So just about everything
Trump is saying there is wrong lie or deceptive,
and it should be interpreted as such. But
the biggest sort of most obvious hypocrisy from
the right at this point in time is they were
always talking about we shouldn't be super tough
with with with Russia. Democrats want us to have
a bad relationship. They want to be strict, they
want a sanction, they want to be tough. And at
the same time now they're saying, well, Biden's
not being tough enough. And we talked about the
sanctions earlier. I do think early they were
weak. They are getting tougher. I also think you
need to leave something on the table in case Putin
does push further into Ukraine. We discussed that
earlier, but Trump's foreign policy analysis worth
basically what we paid for it, which is nothing